everyone welcome to behind the code
today we're gonna be talking all about
the universal analytics upgrade and to
do that we're gonna go right to the
source we have Nick Miele offski joining
us in the studio he's the product
manager who's been working on the
universal analytics upgrade tool working
tirelessly to bring this upgrade to all
of our users so thanks for joining us
Nick yeah thanks for having me here
cool let's take a look at the agenda so
Nick's gonna give us an overview of what
Universal analytics is second thing
we'll do is we'll go through an overview
of the upgrade itself so what is it why
we're doing it and just generally what
the steps are so you know a little bit
more about that next we'll cover some
common questions we've been getting a
lot of questions from developers about
how to use our upgrade tool what that
process looks like also questions about
implementation and code so we'll go
through that as well and Nick will give
us some tips and great context along the
way and then at the end we'll will give
you some resources that you can go to
after the video so if you have questions
or want to find out more about a
particular topic of the upgrade you can
check out the resources and learn more
let's start at a super high level for
those who haven't heard of it before
what is the universal analytics Nick can
you give us an overview yeah that's a
great question
I mean Universal analytics is huge right
it's Universal ok so let me try to
contain it down into something really
basic whoo all right so in the past
Google Analytics has been about tracking
websites and web pages so over the past
15 years we've seen a huge increase in
mobile content consumption consumption
across tablets and even content being
distributed across many other factors
like kiosk game consoles and so what we
saw is a need to create new
infrastructure within Google Analytics
that allows us to track user behavior
across all of these devices so we
launched last year Universal analytics
as a set of features and libraries as
well as infrastructure to allow us to
now enable businesses to measure how
users interact with their business
across all these different devices so
it's a collection you'd say it's a some
infrastructure changes it's also new
reports and new features and also
libraries all bundled together correct
that one all together and what really it
is is a platform price to add additional
functionality and features to really
help users better understand how or how
customers help them understand how users
are interacting with your business
across all these different environments
cool ok so let's talk about the upgrade
then sure so why are we doing an upgrade
what is it that's a good question
when we launched Universal analytics we
required users to create brand new
properties or tracking units and so all
of the historical data that they had was
still being processed by classic
analytics and only new properties are
being processed by Universal analytics
so what the upgrade allows people to do
is to actually upgrade their classic
analytics accounts into Universal
analytics accounts and it features are
fantastic because now you have ability
to get all the power of the new
universal analytics while maintaining
all your historical data you can still
do your over your trends
month-over-month trends pre and post
upgrade but you can also take advantage
of all the brand new features cool so
it's gonna be seamless than in reports
exactly awesome awesome and so how does
how would one upgrade well we try to
make it as simple as possible and we
boil it down into two easy steps the
first step is you actually have to
transfer processing from your classic
analytics to Universal analytics and
that's done through a tool the second
step is to actually retag or
re-implement the tracking code to go
from the classic tracking library to the
new universal analytics library right
now the second step is optional but it's
highly recommended okay so you don't
have to change your code but we
recommend that you don't have to change
it but we recommend you do okay and
maybe we'll talk a little bit more about
that later when we talk more about your
implementation yeah cool now one other
thing that I wanted to ask you because
I've gotten a bunch of questions on this
is there anybody who shouldn't be
upgrading right now because a lot of
people watching this might have the
question and should I upgrade or should
I wait there's there anything people
should know it's a good it's a great
question so today there's many features
in Google Analytics the double-click
integration features the deal with
remarketing
double-click for advertisers these
features the the features that uses the
DCJS tracking code these features were
still working on to support them in
Universal analytics ok so if you are
using any of these features you should
wait just a little bit longer so we have
full support for all the features cool
so if you're using those you shouldn't
use upgrade today the other set of users
who shouldn't do this upgrade is if if
you're not familiar with how you've
implemented to the tracking code make
sure you go to somebody who is more
familiar and make sure that there's no
issues with your implementation that
will break so you want to make sure you
go through all of the you spend the time
learning about what this upgrade is and
the implications it could have again you
know there's many people using Google
Analytics a lot of them get used it in
very creative ways and so if you are
using in a creative way you want to make
sure that you know all the caveats
involved to make sure your up ladies as
seamless as possible and there's no risk
of data quality issues so for example if
you did like a really custom
implementation with gjs on your website
correct you're definitely one of the
people who we would suggest would spend
a little bit more to uptime a time
upfront to figure out if anything's
going to break when you absolutely yeah
cool cool so let's talk about the
upgrade tool did you mentioned there
were two steps right you're going to
transfer your property using a tool and
then you can optionally update the code
yeah so this would be step one using the
upgrade tool correct but what is the
upgrade tool what do you do right well
upgrade tool starts with that admin UI
in Google Analytics
ok I think I have a screenshot so let me
show it and then you can give us a yeah
fantastic so the upgrade tool allows you
to come in to the admin admin UI there's
a new section for upgrading Universal
analytics upgrade under each property so
this happens at the property level so if
you look at a property column you'll see
a new tab for the upgrade when you click
on that you'll actually be able to go
and get to a page that take you through
a series of steps to transfer
prostituting from classic to Universal
analytics so what you do is you come
into the tool you you accept it you look
through the
the information read all the
documentation when you're ready you
click to the next stage you get a dialog
sharing kind of all the little caveats
and details and once you've agreed and
you confirm we actually schedule your
property to be transferred now the the
transfer actually takes between 24 and
48 hours and so you can actually come
back you'll see a little state change
this says transfer in progress and
actually under the tab for universal
analytics upgrade they'll say
transferred progress all right you can
always revisit to see where you are and
what stage you're at once we finally
transferred after that time then it'll
be saying transfer complete
and so that means once the transfer is
done you've completed step one of the
upgrade process okay so that's I click
the transfer button I'm gonna wait 24 to
48 hours check my account and it's gonna
give me a notice that says it's done
right it's that easy that easy cool so
during that time can I still send data
you can continue to send data yeah but
during the time you should not retag to
the new tracking code right do you need
to make sure that you complete step 1
which is the transfer processing before
you move to step 2 which is the actually
reimplementation of tracking code
otherwise if you don't do that there
could lead to data quality issues okay
so transfer wait until we confirm it's
been done in your account and then you
can change your code if you want to
exactly cool so I've gotten this
question from a number of users who
don't actually see the upgrade tool in
their account is there any reason why
someone out there today would not see
the upgrade tool yeah how do they get to
see it so yes it's great
so we wireless that are enabled this
upgrade tool yeah for pretty much all of
the different accounts and the
properties within the only properties
and accounts we haven't enabled it for
is for properties or profiles that are
using any of our double-click
integration features for example
remarketing or double-click for
advertisers
if anybody's have enabled these features
we've explicitly not enabled this tool
for any of the profiles within their
account and the reason why is that we
want to be extra careful because we
don't have full features support for
these features in Universal analytics
we're still working on it
like remarketing exact
right because we don't have the full
feature support for that we don't want
to have somebody accidentally upgrade
their account to something that they
can't use right okay so for those
properties if you don't see this today
don't worry we're just ensuring that
there will be no issues when we actually
do enable it for them I don't got it and
for accounts that have a lot of users
how do you know if somebody else may
have already upgraded your property
which you can do is always come into the
property column and you look at the
upgrade universe I don't like upgrade
tab and you'll always get the status of
where you are whether transfers in
progress or if it's hasn't been done or
if it's complete ok cool so it's in the
admin section look at the property he's
on the universal analytics upgrade tab
great so now let's talk about step two
of the upgrade process which is actually
updating your code so you mentioned that
updating the code is actually optional
right step one transfer your property
but step two is optional right why
wouldn't you update your code or what do
you get from updating your code right so
that when in Universal analytics when we
launch that we also announced a new
tracking code that works what universe
analytics analytics jazz there's a lot
for what yes and so the analytics yes
library is a lot more flexible for
developers so if you are customizing the
code it's a lot easier to customize and
there's a lot more functionality built
to simplify the customization so
customization is a big thing the second
part of it is for large websites for
example with the new tracking code we
only use one cookie the old key tracking
code we use five cookies mm-hm
so because cookies are sent with all the
different requests on the page you
actually can reduce a significant amount
of bandwidth for large sites as well and
finally I think the most important
reason is that all we have a bunch of
new features we're working on with
Universal analytics
we've announced some like user ID these
type of features will only work with the
new tracking code and increasingly we've
kind of have a team mandate that all new
features are built only using Universal
analytics so increasingly we can't talk
about them here but we are working on
many new features that will only be
supported by what we're by the new
analytics j/s tracking library so if you
want access to the latest and greatest
stuff
use analytics jasanoff great my head
right so what can you give us like just
an overview of the changes that you
would need to make as a developer if you
kind of had a simple site and a simple
implementation of GHA s what would you
need to do to get to analytics.js well
the basic implementation for for Google
Analytics on a website is to put a piece
of JavaScript on all the pages of your
site so that piece of JavaScript has
changed with analytics yes so at minimum
you'd have to go through all the
different pages of your site and
implement the new tracking code replace
the old one with the new now for people
who were doing more sophisticated
integrations they have event tracking
social interactions ecommerce the actual
tracking interface the actual methods
that you use on the tracking code have
changed so what you'll need to do is
update all the places where you're
calling the old library with the new
methods that are corresponding to the
new library got it got it
duuude so for some people with big sites
this is actually a pretty sizable amount
of work right yeah do they need to
update everything all at once I mean
could you have on a page
some old ghis code and some new
analytics jas code well it's a great
question and so we've designed these
libraries to work together but there are
some caveats so for a given page the
tracking works at a property ID or a
property ID so this this you a number
you a xxx - why and so for one of those
properties you can only use one tracking
mechanism on a given page so either
using analytics chess or ghs for a given
page now across different pages you we
have made these libraries work together
so you can have the old tracking jgs
code on 50% of pages for one property
okay and for the other 50% you could
have the new one analytics chess or the
same property okay so the problem that
really arises when you actually for the
same property on the same page use
different libraries so for those people
who are planning on retaliating
I'm gonna retag 25% of my pages we can't
access and so Francois the problem comes
when you try to get down on the page
level and say some of this stuff is
gonna be analytics jeaious on this page
the rest is ghs
right exactly yeah okay and that's for a
given property now of course there's
always the sophisticated users right
we're using multiple properties on the
same page right for roll-up reporting or
something like this so if you have
multiple properties on the same page you
can use GHS for one of the properties
and analytics.js for the other property
the problem arises when it's the same
property on the same page with two
different tracking guys I got it is
there any reason to dual tag at this
point we have the upgrade tool so is
there any reason that you would want a
dual tag your site completely with the
old code and the new code or is it just
time to switch over completely so dual
tagging what a lot of people do is
they'll have the old legacy GHS across
their site and then they'll create a new
universal analytics property and then
they'll implement analytics.js with the
new one across their site so your
tagging with two properties because we
didn't have this upgrade to in the past
right now when people compare the data
between the two they're always going to
see a difference because the actual
sequence of when the actual requests are
sent the hits are sent to Google
Analytics differ so we'll always never
you know see a difference so what we
recommend for all users now we have the
upgrade is to actually go through the
upgrade don't dual tag don't create a
new universal analytics property rather
convert your existing one to Universal
analytics and that ensures that the data
is most consistent you have the
historical data and make sure that you
don't have these kind of deltas between
the two tracking codes because they're
firing at a different rate in the
browser right right okay that makes
sense what happens for you so for those
people who are gonna put this off which
I don't hold it against them right right
putting it off what happens if they do
nothing right now so you have gaj s on
your website it's been working fine
let's say you transfer your property
over but you don't actually upgrade your
code right what what happens then so
once you've transferred to Universal
analytics you can still send the data
from the old tracking library that will
continue to work over time you'll see
that more features are added to the
analytics J's library so you want to get
to take advantage of them but will still
collect the old data and process that
okay and and we can look a little bit
into the timeline kind of talk about
like how this will work out in the long
term okay cool let's move so we just
talked about web
and code and implementation issues there
let's move to mobile apps sure so if I
think the users out there who are using
SDK version 1 that's really the library
that we're talking about those are the
people who are going to be upgrading
because version 2 or higher are already
sending hits to Universal analytics so
for those users using version 1 what
does the upgrade process look like for
them is it kind of the same thing as
well it's similar but it's different so
it's important for mobile users to pay
attention yeah
step one of transferring from classic to
Universal analytics continues to work
when you do the transfer you might see
some small differences in the way the
sessions are calculated you might have a
lower number of visits to the site but
there's no way around this this is just
the way that we're changing on how
sessions are calculated between the old
classic and into the new universal
analytics so you might see a slight
decrease in a number of visits in your
reporting profile and that's for
transferring on step one
once you've complete step one you'll
continue to actually view your data in
Google Analytics as a web profile now
when we introduced app tracking last
year we introduced a brand new data
model you have tracking Google Analytics
it was actually really based on
universal analytics right but also came
with a new app tracking data model now
it's all around screen views and in
metrics that made sense for applications
we also created a whole new set of UI
reports specific to apps now those work
with SDK two plus versions but they
don't work what v1 is still using old
page view tracking right so if you are
using v1 you have a couple options one
is to continue using the v1 SDK and
viewing your reports in web profiles is
the standard web profile the second
option you have is you can actually
upgrade to v2 change all your code from
page tracking to app tracking but today
if you view that in analytics you'll
actually have to create a new app
profile and all your data will be an app
profile right so the issue it becomes is
that now all the new data is an app
profile
whereas all old data is in a web
right and so the challenge with that is
that you actually can't trend it over
time because there are different
profiles well you at least to some
reporting challenges guys so if you want
continuity between the data you would
complete step one transfer your property
yeah
don't upgrade your codes still use SDK
v1 and keep sending your hits there and
that will work fine and everything will
be continuous just like you'd expect
correct if you wanted to get access to
the new reporting features for apps all
the new stuff that we've launched for
apps you'd actually have to create a new
app profile or a new app view right and
then upgrade your code and send your
data to that when that causes the break
in continuity correct okay so it's a bit
of a trade-off it's a bit of a trade-off
right now right is it something that
we're working on so by all means like
there's no rush to actually retag to
version 2 but we do recommend at least
looking at step 1 to transfer from
classic to Universal a processing right
so step 1 everybody can do everybody can
do that today it's the REE tagging where
there's a couple considerations got it
cool great so we've covered step one and
step two of the upgrade process I
definitely wanted to ask you more about
the timeline because I'm very people
gonna be wondering when they need to
actually do this stuff and what we're
doing on our end as well
can you speak to so we got four phases
at this time and this is actually unique
because we published our time using we
never published timeline so there's
something yep it's pretty exciting it
yeah we try to be as transparent as
possible so we have four phases we're in
the first phase right cranny walk us
through where we are right now and where
we're where we're going right so phase 1
was really the launch an announcement
that we can actually do this upgrade our
goal at the end of the day is to
transfer 100% of properties from classic
to Universal analytics as well as get
everybody to upgrade and to start only
building features on Universal analytics
so we announced the upgrade so people
can migrate from the classic to end up
until Universal analytics a couple
months ago so that's where we are
phase 2 is that we realized many people
won't actually go through this step one
transferring so what we plan to do is to
start Auto transferring properties from
classic to Universal analytics
so what that means is instead of the
end-users going into the interface and
admin tool and in transferring right
will manually go in and set that bit for
them and then over time their stuff will
be transferred on the processing side so
when does that happen so we've started
with some test accounts and that will
start will start ramping up probably
within the next month or so to start
with small accounts accounts that have
much lower risk of having data quality
issues and then over time as we get full
feature parity will then start ramping
that up to account the larger accounts
accounts with integrations with Adsense
AdWords the double-click and finally the
premium clients will be last in that got
it now phase 3 is once we have full
feature support so again we're missing
some double-click features today
Universal analytics is still in beta and
it doesn't have some of the premium SLA
so our goal is to have one large
announcement that actually takes
Universal analytics out of beta has 100%
feature support full SLA and the goal is
to do that early next year and so once
we do that phase 3 will be ramping up
this Auto transferring of properties
much more will be doing more at a time
and a finally goal or final end goal
once we've reached 100% of properties
transferred to universe analytics is to
then interface for which Universal
analytics becomes the default of Google
Analytics they become the same thing at
that point we will actually announce the
deprecation of the old tracking code jjs
as well as some of the custom variables
got it and so that the announcement of
the deprecation really means we'll
continue to accept and process the data
but we'll do so for a minimum of two
years ok so after two years you know
we'll revisit whether we want to
continue doing that or we want to make
sure that everybody upgrades to the new
tracking code got it okay so Auto
transferring nobody's going to be Auto
transferred who is using a feature that
we don't yet support correct we're
waiting until we have support and then
we'll start moving those accounts right
a lot of people have concerned about
that and we want to make we completely
taking that into account we're being
very cautious on who we transfer and
only once we have full-featured support
and everything
well well we then start enabling it for
you know doing it more broadly and it
sounds like from what you were saying
after when we get to phase four and we
we announced the deprecation of gaj s
there's gonna be a minimum two years
correct so you're good so from today
you've got two years plus of using GHS
of using GHS and yep will support it'll
continue support it okay there is kind
of a nuance there some of the more power
users are using a feature called custom
variables mm-hmm custom variables was
available in GHS in analytics yes we
have something new called custom
dimensions and there is really no
migration between the two that being
said if you are sending custom variables
and you do transfer processing to
Universal analytics we'll continue to
process the custom variables in
Universal analytics there's a legacy
feature but you wouldn't get access to
custom dimensions unless you have
created your code unless you upgraded
the code okay cool cool well we've
covered step one and two of the upgrade
as well as the timeline I just wanted to
quick give everyone some resources that
you can go to after watching this video
so if you want to learn more about how
to upgrade we have this whole upgrade
Center that we've published it's at
developers.google.com slash analytics
slash upgrade you can go there and it
covers migration paths for whatever
library you're using we've documented
how to upgrade from there so definitely
check that out if you have any other
questions on top of that we have a UA
upgrade forum that you can check out and
the link is here on this slide and as I
mentioned at the beginning we're also
going to be doing a follow-up Q&A
session so if you have any questions
that we didn't cover today and I'm sure
there are a bunch out there definitely
post your questions to our Google
moderator and we should have a link to
that below this video so definitely do
that and we'll come we'll be back in
about a month give or take and we'll
answer those questions and hopefully
some more as well
so cool thanks for joining us has been
behind the code all about the universal
analytics upgrade check us out on G+ as
well feel free as I said to check out
our upgrade Center as well if you want
to learn more well catch you next time